West Cambria has come in for an unusual
amount of attention of late this idea of
working to man a typical mid-fifties
male laborer voter in the middle of
leave voting town alighted upon by a
Tory Party think-tank as exactly the
sort of voter the sort of place which
can give the Tory party their first
decent majority since 1987 and yes the
first visitor here was of Boris Johnson
the Tories a poor cloud away from
overtaking labour here to stand any
chance they can't hemorrhage any votes
to Paradas new brexit party they must
keep the leave coalition whole and yet
so why you switched over that's right
it's me how'd you vote last time
conservative in 2017 and you're gonna be
voting brakes biting up its last time I
would a conservative to support trees
are made in brexit but we've been well
and truly betrayed by the Conservative
Party so you voted conservative in 2017
yes Louisa May but now now no way
conservatives if night refer our
geometry with brexit party bleeding the
Tories to compensate no working to man
is a nonsense cliche but here there are
a clutch of key marginals not far from
each other similar to each other and if
in working to them whitehaven and Barrow
and Copeland it is Faraj not Johnson
with particular appeal then because
those people in all those places are
more likely to be levers by definition
it is Johnson not Corbin with the bigger
problem I think in one sense I'm their
biggest nightmare because if I've got
five weeks to get around the country to
say look he's trying to sell you a
second-hand car
the bonnet looks very shiny but once you
lift up the lid and have a look at the
engine it doesn't really it doesn't
really represent value for money if I've
got five weeks at that around the
country I'm gonna be as big as
night--but there's a lot like 2017 and
the conservative vote is unusually feels
unusually soft despite what everyone is
talking about the spy Boris Johnson's
apparent strength it really does feel
unusually soft now you've got this
competitor that we didn't have in 2017
in a former ours and whether you like
him or not he has a genuine resonance
hole for a lot of people in places like
this and it's real it's real in 2017
Theresa May couldn't win historically
labour Workington even without a brexit
party splitting her leave both with yet
another obstacle Boris Johnson might
well have no better luck Lewis got all
Sky News in West Cambria